my guest tonight is a fantastic actress
known for her roles in
shows and films like parks and
recreation mike and dave need wedding
dates
and scott pilgrim versus the world now
you can see her in the film
black bear please welcome our good
friend aubry
plaza aubry's so nice to see you baby
evie baby you know it's me
baby i do know it's you even behind
those glasses i know it's you
you know you look ver there you go there
are those peepers
how are you i'm fine yeah no
i'm doing great first question is yeah
that's real convincing i'm doing great
where am i that's my question for you
is it says there right says you are in
turkey right now
i'm doing a lot of zoom interviews these
days and sometimes people are
you know on the other side of the
country you are in turkey at the moment
what's going on what's that all about
well conan i'm uh shooting a movie here
a guy richie film starring me and jason
statham
[Music]
uh we're following all the uh covid
uh guidelines i've been at quarantine
multiple times
but listen someone's got to save the
film industry
yeah well we reinstate them yeah it's
you and statham in that order if you ask
me
cause i like you statham's fine
but he's so british you know i know
i'm surrounded by the british right now
right because guy richie's
directing it and statham's in it does
that mean you have to talk like them
well you know what's funny is i
i don't know this for sure but when i
read the script
i felt like maybe it was you know
written for a british
person and i just and i there's some
words you know that i don't really say
and i've had to make the choice of like
am i gonna say this
like i'm making fun of them or right am
i gonna commit to this
um and i don't have an answer for that
but um yes sounds like
well i mean does your character because
i do a pretty good english accent you
know
hello
yes pretty good yeah
i like your character stroke victims
oh this place is pretty porsche and
then hey we're going to get the terrace
out of his capital
what's up
how the hell did you get past the
audition yeah you know it's funny
because with those sunglasses on i feel
like i'm doing a drug deal
you know it's just how it feels right
now
i'll give you four apples wow for a
hundred kilos of cocaine
that's yeah that's the best deal i've
had i always buy my cocaine i barter and
i use fresh fruit
and uh it's amazing here in turkey
baby yeah well let's talk about turkey
for a second
hotel room is it pretty nice yeah
it's pretty nice um i would
you know swing the lens around here but
i i
uh i don't know what's good on
television or not yeah you don't want to
and who knows we might see something we
shouldn't see you know
but um truthfully i haven't really been
out of out of the hotel i'm not really
allowed to go anywhere
like i said we're following the copic
guidelines and uh
i'm quarantined so i just stay in my
room like a good
girl yeah well okay so you're saying
that you're behaving yourself
following coping guidelines we got all
that you're staying in a nice hotel room
did they give statham a better hotel
room than you or did you get as good a
hotel room as him
you think he's staying at the hotel room
that i'm staying at no way buddy
he's over at the burnt
i can't say it because people no
he's got stalkers he's got stalkers yeah
guess what me too okay so many ladies
trying to get a piece of this
that i'm not allowed to say where i am
right now you know
yeah where are you by the way i'd love
to say but the minute i say where i
am nine women are gonna grab my ass
and molest me so no i can't oh
my left you oh sorry
wait a minute i love it now let's try
that again with a british accent
see now i'm going to get in trouble with
the hotel staff again because they just
heard you say i'll molest you at the top
of your list
carry on carry on um
[Music]
now let me understand something you've
spent some time in qatar on this trip
haven't you
yes that's right
sorry let me point out
let me point out that there's been no
pre-interview and i have no notes
okay cause you really helped with that
yes
that's right all right listen
did you spend some time in qatar on this
trip okay i thought it was qatar
am i wrong i don't know hey sorry i did
a uso
tour i did a little bit of a military
tour there to sort of
you know raise the spirits or lower the
spirits of the troops
and uh they were calling it cutter okay
you're right
cutter sorry cutter i was saying it
wrong yes i was there
look i don't know what happened and it
wasn't me
i was only there for two days okay
everything's fine but here's my question
you got to be very careful in a place
like qatar
uh because they are very strict about
drugs even drugs that we may consider to
be rather
mild drugs aubrey you know what i'm
talking about
what like the mary jane
yeah i know that you like to puff on the
old
weed-a-roo once in a while you like a
jazz cigarette occasionally
first of all that's legal in california
baby you heard it here first
right it's legal in california but you
take one of your
gummy bears and you know the kind i'm
talking about
you take one of those to cutter you take
one of those to the middle east you
could end up in jail for 15 years
they'll take away your sunglasses look
full disclosure
i this was beaten into me before i got
on the plane to cut her
they told me do not test it aubry
and i said fine i'll eat all my gummies
in the car ride
over to the airport and i did
and then i got to the airport and i
found out that we were delayed three
hours
see normally you get into the airport
and you get on the plane
and you just fly right high into the sky
this time i ate the gummies went into
the airport
met guy richie and stayed them for the
first time and then was
very quickly told we had a three hour
maybe four hour delay
and i had to break the news to them
mommy ate some gummies
you being mommy yeah so you told them
mommy ate some gummies
and then you tripped out didn't you i
mean
you were feeling no pain tell you what i
did on my gummies
what i do on my gummies is my own time
no business business
i don't know what happened okay i know
that we eventually got on the plane
and now we're shooting a movie
that's all you need to know you know
what do you what else do you need to
know you're
in turkey you have no gummies on you
right now
yes you're in turkey
okay good oh what else you really
tripped me up
it really tripped you up i heard someone
told me
that during quarantine this you know
this last year you've been getting into
witchcraft
a little bit experimenting is that true
or false
yeah it's true but listen i want to say
that
um i'm not an expert
i don't pretend to know you know all the
secrets of the dark arts
i'm an apprentice to a fourth generation
witch
called dandelion who lives across the
street from me
i'm blessed that she has taken me under
her
advisement and uh learned a lot
seen a lot and uh i'm just dabbling
okay you're dabbling in the dark arts
and that's fine that's something a lot
of people do
in show business um my question is
what are your powers have you learned to
do anything can you
can you read into the future can you
what can you do what have you
learned with your witchcraft
apprenticeship
one thing is i've been getting very good
at readings i have my cards right here
okay um you know mainly what i do is i
just harness the energy of the moon the
stars
the galactic cosmic
void right into my
and and i use it for the power of good
uh-huh okay and
and sometimes i change someone's life
like yours conan
really right now i'm harnessing
the energy of the mediterranean sea
which is very nearby my room
i feel the waves i hear you my
darling and i will harness this energy
right into the cards
now conan yeah i don't control
the outcome of these readings so if i
pull a card that you don't like
that's on you baby
you heard it here first okay all right
so what do i do do i pick one or is it
just gonna appear
now i'm gonna just slowly cascade these
cards down
and when you get the feeling deep down
inside of you
you say hold it mama i think those are
just bar coasters but anyway
uh hold on
now mama
oh conan this is a good
card baby this is the four of disks
four of disks what's happening in that
it looks like someone's trying to flee a
small apartment that's on fire
you're right this does not look
promising no that does not look like i
wanted to get a card where like
a naked guy's with a naked lady and it's
all about
sex and my sexuality and
this woman wants out she wants out of
your life conan
the woman that's closest to you is not
happy that's my wife
fleeing our marriage as if the house is
on fire is that what you're saying
your marriage is the fire conan and you
have not been tending to it
no i have not been tending those fires
and that's my wife or is that jesus
i don't pretend to know your religion
these cards are up for interpretation
but i will say that that's a very
small hole she's trying to crawl out of
look like i said i'm an apprentice
okay but i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna for real i'm gonna email you
later and tell you what this really
means
okay do tell me what that means because
it looks doesn't look good it looks like
yeah looks like my wife is unhappy with
the marriage and is trying to get out
of our tiny hut that we live in i don't
want to
i don't want to be presumptuous but that
could be you
i mean doesn't that kind of look like
you you know if my hair was a little
longer that could be me
and it doesn't look like it's a door it
i don't know what that is
it looks like a space to hide something
in i'm very intrigued i love it
like i said i don't control the outcome
nope
only your destiny baby yep you've told
me absolutely nothing
and i enjoyed it um you know we got
it perhaps you will
so you've had no gummies in a while is
that what you're saying
this is you with no gummies
i'm high on turkey honey
apple gobble okay yes gobble gobble
the turkish people love it when we
pretend it's the actual bird
listen
listen just saying hello to my neighbors
very nice
let's talk about this other movie that
you're promoting right now a movie
you've already made an independent film
black bear this is quite an interesting
movie
a lot of different perspectives in this
film a lot of different ways
for it to be interpreted what would you
like to say about black bear
well i'd like to say that this was a
passion project
and uh i'm very proud of it it's a very
dark
uh you know psychologically um
effed up movie and uh
but um but it features great
performances
by christopher abbott sarah gaston and
um
and uh but for real it's a great movie
yeah
buy it now rent it now get your mind
blown
you haven't seen anything like it it's a
it's a fascinating film
and uh the first part of the movie is
sort of a response to the i mean the
second part of the movie sort of a
response to the first part of the film
i've said too much already it's a
fascinating film
and uh i think all the posters say
it's psychologically effed up no one's
said that about a film since herbie the
love bug
so you should be proud let's not forget
hey i want to ask you about something um
you and i have bibled and babbled
but today uh president-elect
joe biden gave a very emotional speech
as he left to become president to the
people of delaware
you're from delaware did this and you
listened to this speech this must have
had real meaning for you
i just i was just watching it on my
phone right before you got in your chair
and i
almost started crying i mean yeah i love
that man i'm so proud of him i'm so
proud to be a delawarean
and uh i cannot wait to for tomorrow
and in fact it almost is tomorrow here
that's right
45 minutes and uh and uh
and i'm just yeah i just his speech
touched me like
he's just a real person and he has a
soul and he has empathy and he
believes in our country and our in our
people and uh
and i'm just my heart is full
no jokes conan no this is the part
that's serious
uh there's no screwing around i take my
glasses off still but
i i mean it like i'm just i'm so
uh you're very happy and because you're
because you're in turkey
biden's going to become president
earlier for you than for us
yeah that doesn't no that's not true um
he you know it's doesn't make any sense
what i just said
you know the turkish people are very
proud of him
right now i can speak for turkey you
know i think you do speak for turkey in
many ways
what says turkey more than aubry plaza
in a robe and sunglasses
in a hotel room that quite frankly could
be here in l.a i'm just taking your word
for it that you're in turkey
um you've done nothing to prove that you
were in turkey except show me four
apples in cellophane
how does that prove you're in turkey
don't
tempt me to take my laptop down the
hallway and get into some real trouble
okay i won't we won't do that you know
you talked about delaware
there's a movement in delaware because
you're from there
to change the name of columbus square to
aubrey plaza plaza how do you feel about
that
i support listen google maps has already
officiated this if you look on google
maps where the columbus statue used to
be
it does say the aubrey plaza plaza i
didn't do it
that's great i didn't ask for this but
if
if the people want to give it to me i
will i won't let them down
i'll come up with the right you know
person to put on that
block of cement and it and it won't be
you know someone shitty
that's an eloquent speech about what
should happen in that space
i'll work on my speech if you do end up
giving a speech there please
yeah you'll you'll get there um aubry
i miss you you're all the way in turkey
and uh let's face it when you and i get
together in person
there's always chemistry um you can't
deny it
we can't deny it you know hey you gotta
get me out of here
no you've got a movie to make you're
making a guy richie film
this is a big deal they're gonna edit
this and make it better right
no we can't afford that look at me i'm
in an abandoned theater
i'd tell you where but a bunch of ladies
would jump these bones
i will molest you damn it
black bear that's the film that's out
right now it's available now
on demand get that film it's terrific
it's going to blow your mind
uh aubry god bless you take care
and um when you get back come see me you
know we'll all be vaccinated by then
and uh you and i can do what we always
did which is drive around the city
and talk about the old times
can't wait conan and guess what i hope
that you vaccinate me
with your
my marriage guess what guess what
my marriage is now in trouble
all right aubry plaza thank you very
much that was great